[Music]
when I was in grade school
I was bullied for being asian-american
and the biggest problem with that is
that I am NOT asian-american but when I
was younger and this is absolutely true
people thought that I might be Asian
American I have pretty thin eyes I had
very thin eyes when I was a little kid
and I had straight black hair that I
wore in a bowl cut and from the ages of
3 to 8 people thought that I might be a
young Chinese person on the first day
that he met me the guy that is now my
best friend he met me the first day of
kindergarten
he went home that night and said Papa
today I met a boy with no eyes and that
was me kids would make fun of me in
middle school kids would call me a
[ __ ] which of the racial slurs has
got to be the laziest that is just
pushing two words together no work was
done there it was very confusing to me
because I'm not Chinese known in my
family is a remotely Asian I mean we
take our shoes off when we come inside
but that's more of a carpeting thing
than anything else here's how bad it got
though I remember when I was in junior
high we had this music appreciation
class that we never appreciated and they
took us to hear some classical music
once at a Symphony Orchestra so we go to
a symphony orchestra in one of these
classical pieces there's a moment where
they bang a gong and every time they
banged the gong all the kids sitting in
front of me would stand up turn to me
and bow like that
which is some racist ass [ __ ]
but also incredibly well coordinated for
a group of 13 year olds 13 year olds are
the meanest people in the world they
terrify me to this day if I'm on the
street on like a Friday at 3:00 p.m. and
I see a group of 8th graders on one side
of the street I will cross to the other
side of the street because 8th graders
will make fun of you but in an accurate
way they will get to the thing that you
don't like about you they don't even
need to look at you for long they'll
just be like ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
look at that high waisted man he got
feminine hips and I'm like now that they
got sensitive about
[Music]
when I was a boy I was also confused
with a woman sometimes over the phone
because before I went through puberty I
had a voice like a little flute I was
once on the telephone with Blockbuster
Video which is a very old fashioned
sentence and it is I was on the
telephone with Blockbuster Video that's
like when your grandma would be like
we'd all go play jacks down at the soda
fountain you're like no one knows what
you're talking about you idiot you know
how you talk to your grandma so I was on
the phone with Blockbuster I'd called
them a couple of times in one day to ask
about a movie and I called for a third
time I said hey yeah
I was just calling to see if you had
Addams Family Values yet and the guy had
blockbuster went hey lady I'll tell you
when we get Addams Family Values but
look I wasn't offended as a boy being
confused with a lady I was offended as a
lady who's getting pushed around by this
chauvinist [ __ ] that works at
Blockbuster Video talking to me like I'm
some floozy I am a proud Asian American
woman and you will treat me with respect
I am a tiger mom
hey here's why I didn't get attitude I
would tell you I didn't get attitude
okay I didn't get answered because I
remember my first time cussing my first
time cussing was my mom smacked me in
front of company
my friends was over the house I'm
downstairs you playing we having a good
time my mom come down said she said hey
I told you to keep it down you don't run
in this house I do okay with that being
said that's it you're done go to bed mmm
smacking sent me up to my room now you
know when you get smacked when you a kid
you get height when you get by yourself
you want smack me [ __ ]
[Applause]
I was emotional I was an emotional hands
kid I'm writing away I pack the bag and
everything you know many times I pack
the bag with a toy pack the bag with
what toy I'm out I'm sick of it me and
he-man are out my mom gave me my mom
gave me permission to cuss one time one
time she gave me permission to cuss I'm
in school I'm being bad my teacher got
mad that Kevin come here
somebody comes to the front of the class
wrote a note stay with a note to my
chest that make sure your mother read to
know I get home my mom read the note the
note said maybe if you showed your son
some more attention at home he wouldn't
act like a fool in school right my mom
read that no she said let me tell you
something
you tell her mind her damn business
before I come down there and I beat her
ass I thought okay do you want me to say
it like that or do you want me I'm gonna
take some stuff out we're not saying
tell her mind her damn business before I
come down there and I'd be fast I said
no I heard what you say I just wanna
make sure that you notice you telling me
to say the same thing Kevin if I tell
you again imma smack the [ __ ] at you
okay now I got it okay
okay okay okay all right okay
keep in mind it's a lot of pressure all
right my mom just gave me permission to
go to school because my teacher out I
didn't feel comfortable situation so I
went to practice I want to go upstairs I
wanna go over the lines so I'm in the
mirror I'm going over my lines I'm not
okay all right okay all right okay my
mom told me to tell you to buy your girl
nice too loud
that's way too loud that's not
believable it's too loud
finally I'd go over it I get it down I'm
like you know what I'm gonna go to bed
early get some rest because I got a big
day ahead of me tomorrow I don't I don't
know mess this up so I go to bed I wake
up get dressed put on my pants and my
shirt
I give him a school bus all my friends
see me they get high Oh candies on the
bus everybody look calves on the bus
what up keV I was like yo not today
y'all I got a lot of stuff on my mind I
can't really have y'all throwing me off
and my friend was like what you're
talking about so I can't really get into
it all I can tell y'all is that it's
about to go down he's like what I said
look man it's about to go down just be
behind me when I walk in class he's all
right cool I walk in class miss green my
teacher she starts speaking everybody
hello good morning good morning hello
hello good morning she seen me she's
like Kevin I said miss green she's had
this let your mother read the note I
said yes I did
she said well what does your mother say
I took a deep breath I looked at my
friends I was like it's about to go down
I said well uh my mom told me to tell
you to mind your damn mother [ __ ]
business
no stupid [ __ ] look buddy Pizza [ __ ]
2+2 not know what the [ __ ] it is [ __ ]
crawl sighs crying down your backpack go
dance [ __ ] long-hidden own it won't
have an
this the [ __ ] that was crazy
my friends in the background is there
he's they're sharing had no nipple I got
suspended I got suspended and a hooker
my mom beat the [ __ ] out of me when I
got home I told you to stay to cuss
words you said 76 up I thought I was
samuel l.jackson I'm sick of tired of
these [ __ ] teaches his
[ __ ] school had a trench coat
on a flat tip [ __ ]
I'll tell you a quick childhood story
I'll tell you one of the funnier ones
right one time when I was like six my
older brother was eight we were in the
backseat of my dad's car and we will
like laughing and we were excited
because it was around Christmas right
and my dad just had this thing he just
didn't like joy you know
so he's sitting there driving he's going
like Jesus Christ knock it off back
there clash you don't straighten up I'm
gonna buy you a doll for Christmas and
then he did I swear to God
he made us hold them up my mother's
taking pictures in front of the
Christmas tree I'm just standing there
like afterwards I ran upstairs to my top
bunk my dad knew he [ __ ] up to his
credit he came up he tried to smooth it
over he's like all right come on back
down it's over come on down enjoy the
holiday he eventually coaxed me down you
know he just he softened up a little bit
look you don't get your [ __ ] ass back
downstairs no one else could open that
gift I bought it out my side though that
out I'll go back downstairs all
shell-shocked here's another gift for
you Billy I'm like is this a [ __ ]
dollhouse where does it end
yeah that was Christmas and those were
people that loved me I had a guy slow
playing me at a lake there was a guy
that used to run around the lake and
talk to us with more efficient but
probably like 13 me and my friend Josh
in particular we would go this one Lake
it was in our town and we'd fish there
all the time
and this dude would come by all the time
and visit he was always friendly start
off real normal what do you guys up to
catches the fish like southern accent
seems I got an old gentleman and then a
couple of times he came when it was just
me and then he just sat down next to me
and talked to me and I was naive I was
13 I just thought he was a real nice guy
like almost like a older brother type
figure it's gonna give you a good advice
he talked about cool [ __ ] he was a
teacher he got kicked out of his
position for some unfair reason he
wouldn't really be specific about it but
he said you know they didn't like the
way he taught and so anyway this dude
just becomes my friend like nice and
slow nice and slow brings me lunch I
even went to his house once and then one
day I am fishing and he's drunk and he
tells me he loves me and I said I think
I said something I really like you too
he goes you know there there can't be
love without sex and I remember thinking
what whoa like what did he just what
happened
and then I might remember thinking what
a dummy I am I thought this guy just
liked me he was I was his buddy he's
gonna teach me things he just likes
teaching people it's just really smart
that I had my hand on a knife I had a
Swiss Army knife from them little red
plastic ones you know the ones with the
camp yeah they have all the kind of [ __ ]
and all I was thinking is I put it in my
hand in my pocket like I held on to it
and I remember thinking god damn it I
hope I don't have to [ __ ] try to use
this cuz I was thinking it's like he was
a big guy you know I was 13 I don't know
what I weighed 120 pounds or something
I might [ __ ] this guy might beat the
[ __ ] out of me and raped me here in the
woods like he was bigger than me and he
was always jogging you know it wasn't in
bad shape and he I told him get the [ __ ]
away from me
and he told me not be upset and then I
left I got away he didn't chase me I you
know he didn't want to be violent he
wanted to trick me in the [ __ ] you come
he wanted he didn't want to rape me he
wanted to trick me into [ __ ] him I
got real lucky that that was the case
but then years later I got a letter from
I'm at my house that was creepy because
it showed up in the mailbox like he had
figured out where I moved to and sent me
a letter
oh whoa and it was like real like
friendly and professional like a real
professor like a scholar I don't even
remember if you ever apologized but it
was real weird I was like whoa I dodged
that bullet